it's the new week and that means it's
time for new releases you're probably
wondering where Mary is and I'm here to
tell you Mary is that pack so it looks
like you get me this week are you ready
to slash and swipe your way through a
colorful first-person dungeon crawler I
know I am if you own a Vita which I'm
sure many of you probably don't you can
pick up drinkbox studios latest game
severed side note if you haven't played
drink boxes last game called guacamelee
stop this video and go play it seriously
it's really good in severed you plays a
warrior named Sasha as she navigates a
vibrant nightmarish world in search of
her family use the touchscreen to slice
enemies apart collect sets of armor and
upgrade Sasha you can start slicing and
dicing on April 26th you don't own a
Vita you say we'll remember that little
game called resogun that launched with
the PlayStation 4 well house marks next
game releases this week and it's called
alienation alienation is an explosive
top-down shooter the two team up with
three friends and ward off an alien
invasion players will be able to
experiment with different classes
upgrade their character skills and
customize their weapons the invasion
begins on April 26
if survival horror is more your thing
then you might want to check out back in
1995 back in nineteen ninety-five is a
throwback to classic horror games from
well 1995 the game features nostalgic 3d
graphics a CRT looking display and fixed
camera angles oh and of course tank
controls if this sounds like your thing
you can explore the desolate cityscape
on April twenty-eighth if you've been
keeping up with hitman and you'll be
pleased to know that episode 2 will
launch this week from cathedrals two
mansions and marketplaces to alleyways
there's bound to be hundreds of ways to
eliminate your targets starting on the
26 you and that bald-headed assassin can
visit the beautiful beachside city of
sapienza now how about a free game mini
Mario and Friends amiibo challenge comes
to 3ds and Wii U in mini Mario and
friends you can scan your meebo and
guide them through dangerous levels
filled with traps and enemies there are
more than 60 levels and it supports more
than 20 amiibos you can give that a try
on the 28 normally a burden John Rambo
don't have a lot in common but that's
all about to change with rocket birds to
evolution an evil totalitarian penguin
regime has risen up as they tend to do
and it's up to the protagonist hard
boiled chicken to put an end to these
evil penguins the game will have a
single player mode and a four-player
multiplayer mode rocket burns two flaps
its way on the PlayStation 4 invita on
the 26
the third and final chapter of
Telltale's The Walking Dead Michonne
will hit digital storefronts this
episode is titled what we deserve as I'm
sure you've come to expect all your
choices will determine who lives and
dies in this final episode what we
deserve will be available on almost
every platform imaginable starting april
26 will you be picking up any of these
games let me know in the comments below
and remember that these games are based
on retailer listings and sometimes they
change we'll see you next week
you